c'est un coup de théâtre bien orchestré
jean luc mélenchon en haut de la fiche
pour défier emmanuel macron
le décor le siège de la france sont
soumises les spectateurs des
journalistes qui tresse jours durant
vont suivre les négociations
vous voyez
tel alceste jean luc mélenchon était un
peu jusque là le misanthrope de la
politique française
le voilà devenu l'incarnation de la
gauche il réalise son ambition intime le
nir tout entière derrière son programme
la longueur de la construction
uniquement son programme
un parti socialiste à l'agonie
vous aurez imaginer que la survie du ps
je suis un insoumis aujourd'hui on en
reparlera précédemment construction
honnêtement on n'avait pas l'impression
de discuter avec le même parti
socialiste que il ya deux ou trois ans
de ça
à cette fois ci on est sur une aventure
qui peut être une aventure
extraordinaire tout peut changer la vie
des gens
est ce la fin d'une malédiction
proférées en 2016 contre la gauche
française
parfois il ya des positions
irréconciliables à gauche et il faut
l'assumer
c'est en tout cas le dénouement d'une
présidentielle porteuse d'espoir pour
elle et fip et tragique pour le parti
socialiste comme une répétition de 2017
on benoît hamon avait rassemblé 6,3 pour
cent des suffrages trois fois moins que
jean luc mélenchon
et cette phrase qui prend aujourd'hui
tout son sens
la gauche n'est pas mort je sais que
vous n'attendez pas une recomposition
d'appareils les arrangements d'un vieux
monde politiciens épuisé par une
cinquième république elle-même à bout de
souffle
nous allons vous raconter comment et
pourquoi la gauche française s'est
aligné sur les positions radicales de la
france insoumise
d'un côté
françois hollande à la fois retiré des
affaires mais toujours à l'affût de
l'autre
jean luc mélenchon qui analyse pourquoi
sa radicalité va dans le sens de
l'histoire
si je suis pas d'exalter des valeurs
tout à fait nécessaire faut arriver à
proposer une politique pour le pays et
auxquels se politique à laquelle le pays
peut adhérer ses salles à la grande
condition et pour ça il faut que la
force motrice soit une force de gauche
de responsabilité pas de gauche radicale
on aura
sous-estimer la situation qui me rend
possible
c'est surtout ça et je veux dire la
situation de radicalité de l'existence
qui fait que des gens comme moi peuvent
atteindre de tels niveaux de vote
[Musique]
convention de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale la
fameuse nubes
le nom du costume commun au dossier par
les insomnies les socialistes les
écologistes et les communistes dès le
premier tour des législatives
[Musique]
tu peux rentrer
et ul la prise de photos avec
afp de l'entrée les deux jeux de la côte
et d'en face de la poste hier françois
foucart qui est sur place si tu as
besoin
ça fait plaisir de pouvoir se retrouver
la gauche assure ça c'est du possible
déchirement mais aussi des moments où
s'entassent dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles et qui pourrait
peut-être perdurer mais là tout reste à
construire
pierre jouve est tout sourire à 36 ans
c'est lui qui a négocié l'accord au nom
des socialistes le ps a accepté de
n'être représentait que dans 70
circonscription elle est fille laide ont
plus de 330 un renoncement dicté par la
convergence des luttes à rebours des
éléphants du parti
critique face à cette union ça fait 15
ans qu'on était dans un moule politique
où on se tapait dessus puis apprend
s'aperçoit qu'on parle le même langage
et qu'on h en toi même objectif un même
but c'est un changer la vie des gens et
deuxièmement sur tout et ça je crois que
c'est le plus important construire la
gauche que nous voulons pas celle qu'on
nous a apprise mais celle que nous
voulons
s'il vous plaît
qui sauvent génération au sein du ps
vous pensez peut-être en tout cas moi
que la délégation socialiste que avec
laquelle nous avons discuté on a appris
à se connaître ça veut pas dire qu'on
est d'accord sur tout mais on a essayé
justement ne pas être empoisonnée j'ai
envie de dire par des vieilles lutte qui
ne nous regardez pas mais peut-être que
ça va faciliter les choses
leur programme commun s'appuie sur 650
mesures parmi elles trente trois ont été
laissés en suspens faute de consensus
sur l'europe l'otan ou le nucléaire
c'était nos différences mais aussi nos
accords et qu'en fait la plage commune
que nous avons l'espace commun que nous
après bientôt dix ans
cette journée prend vite des allures de
panégyriques d'une gauche antilibérale
olivier faur le patron des socialistes
remettre publiquement en cause
l'héritage du quinquennat ou non
alors je vais vous faire une confidence
ou plutôt vous rappeler quelque chose la
loi travail de 2016 baptisé el ghomri
attend les
attendait
aucun socialiste ne l'a jamais adopté
pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'elle nous a
été imposée que 49 3 parce qu'il n'y
aurait pas eu de majorité pour l'adopter
c'est ça la réalité
ici on garde le souvenir des lois
travail ou de celle portée par emmanuel
macron alors ministre de l'économie
adopté au forceps
vécues comme des marqueurs de la
politique d'hier et ont pas vraiment de
gauche de françois hollande
comme françois hollande président de la
république se présente à une conférence
de presse qui avec une solennité absolue
dit un peu tout le monde sait que c'est
l'offre qui crée la demande ce jour là
le comment dire il a fini de détruire ce
qui lui avait été confiée tout
quinquennal de gauche à des actifs je
prends pas simplement du mariage pour
tous je pense à ce que nous avons été
capables de faire pour donner davantage
de sécurité sociale à l'ensemble des
français permettent la retraite à 60 ans
pour ceux qui avaient des carrières
longues d'avoir le tiers-payant d'avoir
la couverture maladie pour les
complémentaires santé comme ce bilan n'a
pas été menée par le parti socialiste la
trace laissée est porté d'ailleurs par
le ps a été la trace d'un quinquennat
honteux et bien il ne faut pas s'étonner
que les électeurs ne reviennent pas sont
là vers le ps et que la prime a été
donnée à celui qui était le plus radical
le plus construit dans ses aspects
programmatiques dans l'incarnation du
leadership la france a soumises jean luc
mélenchon
au cours du premier quinquennat macron
politiquement la contestation sociale
est essentiellement incarné par la
france en soumises
en 2017 le ps fut déjà victime du
siphonnage de ses troupes et de ses voix
par la république en marche durant cinq
ans trente députés socialistes sièges à
l'assemblée mais ils semblent inaudibles
comparer aux 17 ans soumis qui adopte la
stratégie du bruit et de la fureur
inspiré des mois de l'armée
moi je viens comme député reporter donc
je prends mes petites notes dans mon
cahier va jouer noté salaires se démener
s'entendre dire qu'on est des feignants
l'école c'est un hôpital que les autres
moi mon boulot c'est de ramener cette
réalité là haut dont la rue dans les
sondages vous le répète rendez-le yessef
d'abord rodez me sf d'abord votre parole
madame la ministre ne vont absolument
rien non la france n'est pas une
start-up que dirige un petit génie vous
ne fait qu'un seul geste en direction du
peuple vous le bâillonner
la soul où il parle pas l'institution il
parle au peuple c'est une règle c'est à
chaque fois qu'il ouvre la bouche il
sait qu'il ya une caméra en face il ya
un micro et qu' ils parlent pas à
monsieur machin monsieur truc où madame
bidule pour dire et convenir où il
faudrait mettre un certain nombre de
formes des relations normales qu'ils ont
par ailleurs avec les gens par le grand
nombre et donc on parle cru est drôle
c'est la consigne et ça je pense que ça
va rester pourquoi parce que c'est la
condition pour être entendus nous si
vous voulez notre point de départ c'est
pas c'est qu'ils nous ont envoyé là ça
aussi ça renouer un lien par exemple je
sais pas vous avez dû vous en rendre
compte qu'il y avait plein de gens qui
regardent maintenant des émissions de
l'assemblée nationale vous êtes parce
qu'avant il faut que la gauche se mette
en situation de pouvoir en 2027
gouverner gagné conquérir diriger et
ensuite durer c'est ça l'enjeu si c'est
simplement pour entretenir la flamme et
qu'ils aient jamais de de feu à la fin
c'est pas ce que je pense être le devant
de la gauche
échange entre un citoyen croisé par
hasard dont le rer et un futur député
nubes lorsque j'entends la réaction des
et plus il sent prêt allier le côté à
mélenchon et ils disent souvent
génération il va trop dans la dent
dans l'affrontement c'est à dire il s'en
prend un trou gens
la gauche insoumise ramène à la
politique une partie de l'électorat
populaire
grigny dans l'essonne la ville la plus
pauvre de france 50 % de la population
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté suivi de
campagne pour les législatives
c'est moi qui suis candidat pour être le
député rappelle antoine voyez c'est moi
à côté de mélenchon c'est moi même si
j'ai même si j'ai un bon bain super
merci beaucoup bonne soirée
c'est moi le candidat et les chiens un
appui décisif
philippe riou un enfant de la grande
borne le maire de la ville depuis dix
ans ça va super
c'est pour les élections
et lé chien un avantage
on va passer plus de 3000 références sur
toute la france dans des immeubles des
relais d'opinion
on n'a pas envoyé mélenchon gouverner le
pays à la présidentielle mais avec ces
élections là on peut encore l'envoyer
gouverner p lui c'est le candidat pour
qu'il soit notre député soutenu par jean
luc mélenchon on a besoin d'avoir un
député qui soit avec nous et qui nous
aident enfin il n'y a pas une voix qui
doit manquer si vous voulez voter pour
moi vous voter pour jean luc mélenchon
et antoine moment il sera un très très
gros comme sa levée vous pouvez pas le
rater
à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup bonne soirée au
revoir
il est combat pour la population n'ont
pas été portées depuis extrêmement
longtemps par par le haut par les
députés qui se sont succédé ce soit
malek boutih ou pire à la raf en de la
majorité les deux d'ailleurs dans les
majorités présidentielles mais les
boutiques dans la majorité de françois
hollande pierre allard a faim dans la
majorité de
emmanuel macron
dans l'adversité où le silence or on a
besoin de changer les choses ici au fil
du temps le ps n'a pas su garder les
voix des classes populaires attiré par
le vote d'extrême droite où l'abstention
elle est fille tente de changer la donne
lui c'est le futur député
tu vois ta belle visite
voilà je vais pas dire deux fois
j'avais ma gagner les campagnes
ressemble à celui ci s'en serait à
vendre a gagné des contrats m enfin on
aura un député avec nous ça va être bien
sera aidée pour green
ça va être bien
à bientôt pour toi merci merci nous
avons ouvert sera ainsi versée
pourquoi
merci il a dit bon courage
et les élections sont vécues comme un
affrontement bloc contre bloc j'ai
l'impression que ces élections prennent
des allures de lutte des classes
ouais bah c'est bien on est tourné dans
ce moment politique
on est dans ce moment politique donc oui
un bloc populaire et il faut que ce bloc
populaire deviennent majoritaires dans
ce pays pour que nos vies échanges donc
oui c'est une des classes
nous sommes premiers dans les 10 % des
villes les plus pauvres du pays nous
sommes en tête de loin chez les chômeurs
des précaires
et ainsi de suite c'est à dire que dans
toute cette partie qui au fond a été
longtemps méprisé par les gens qui ma
foi s'en sortait un et qui en quelque
sorte leur jailbreak a fait un effort on
y arriverait cela ils étaient abandonnés
de tous et tout le monde et une bonne
partie d'entre eux d'ailleurs continue
par effet miroir à dix rebelles
voulaient pas de notre bien nous non pas
de vous un territoire il faut aussi dire
mais pourquoi nous avons perdu le
pouvoir il ya sans doute des raisons
pourquoi il ya eu les catégories
populaires qui ont décroché qu'est-ce
qui doit justifier une nouvelle police
dès le départ la nuque sc perçue par une
partie des socialistes comme un accord
d'appareils parisien unis sous tutelle
de leur parti par la france insoumise en
occitanie met une fronde sous
l'impulsion de la présidente de région
on est visée on est ici à part ça se
prenait 17 au cours des 10
au premier tour des législatives
rémi branco est un dissident de gauche
il se présente contre la candidate
désignée par la nuit baisse une
candidate elle est fille mais lui est
soutenu par la pasionaria de la
social-démocratie carole delga
moi j'ai pas le sentiment de changer
peut-être que d'autres charges moi je
suis fidèle à mes convictions donc dont
je suis un très petit son dissident à
leur histoire dissidents à leur
engagement moi je suis fidèle à ses
engagements
dans sa seule région carole delga
soutien 14 candidats dissidents dans
toute la france ils sont ainsi 60 à se
présenter avec l'appui de françois
hollande ou bernard cazeneuve
pour eux la cornue baisse serait trop
flou sur le fond
de nombreux sujets où il est écrit que
ça sera la sagesse des parlementaires
donc moi quelle je soutiens candidat
quand je soutiens un projet c'est en
connaissance de cause donc moi je
souhaite avoir des positions très
claires des candidats aux législatives
sur la question de la lutte contre le
communautarisme sur la question de la
relation avec l'entreprise sur la
question des européennes voire à pessac
l'attelage bronco delga séduit
assez gentil merci
chez moi c'est le
maintien
rémi branco y croit d'autant plus que le
parti du président n'a pas investi deux
candidats sur sa circonscription je
pense qu'à part une idole de toujours et
sensibilités différentes il faut qu'au
premier tour on choisit ce et au
deuxième tour par contre on s'unit pour
battre la droite ça a toujours été comme
ça mitterrand à gagner comme ça hollande
à gré comme ça carole delga gagner comme
ça et demain aux législatives je regagne
comme ça
malgré son optimisme
rémy brancourt n'a pas passé la barre du
premier tour en arrivant derrière la
candidate une hôtesse les filles
même en occitanie la dissidence n'a pas
pris
40 belga envisagé sans aucun doute
quelque chose de beaucoup plus important
de manière à pouvoir peser après les
élections législatives et peut-être de
s'adresser à ses camarades socialistes
en leur disant ben regarde et on peut
aussi arriver sans eux il y avait aussi
l'idée de démontrer que en dehors de la
coalition de la nuque
le parti socialiste aurait pu avoir
presqu'autant de député je pense que ça
c'était une perspective assez optimiste
quand on partait quand même des scores
ou d'anne hidalgo et des scores dans les
circonscriptions qui était à l'image du
score national voire de très très
nombreuses circonscriptions ce qu'on
appelle les dissidents ont fait à peu
près 10% 10 à 12 % et 10 à 12% c'est
cinq fois plus que anne hidalgo à
l'élection présidentielle ou même que
benoît hamon en 2017 donc c'est à peu
près le socle aujourd'hui à partir
duquel il est possible de reconstruire
il est arrivé que des gens fassent 10%
et empêche un hub est d'arriver au
deuxième tour et que du coup ça donne l
heure n est que ce soit elle qui
l'emportent donc eux qui font toujours
la leçon morale à tout le monde n'en
font pas trop encombré
cette guerre de gauche a été singulière
dans la dernière circonscription détenue
par le parti socialiste à paris durant
la campagne des législatives
tout un symbole la bataille se passe
dans le 19ème et le 20ème arrondissement
un quartier populaire
lamia et la rage et la députée sortante
logiquement candidate de la gauche au
premier tour mais les accords nubes lui
ont préféré danielle simonnet une proche
de jean luc mélenchon conseillère
municipale de paris
un choix qui a fait des remous au point
de mobiliser l'homme qui incarne la
gauche plurielle dont le bilan est
assumée par toutes les gauches
je crois que j'ai toujours été pour
l'union mais bien sûr pas j'ai négocié
avec images et des communistes pourquoi
lamia el harrach des députés sortants
socialistes
seuls députés c'est d'une femme sur
target favorables à l'accord pourquoi il
pendant accord je comprends pas je
trouve ça injuste et donc je le
manifeste lionel jospin connaît bien
danielle simonnet
karl est une ancienne socialiste qui a
claqué la porte du parti en 2008 en même
temps que jean luc mélenchon pour poser
les bases de l efi alors ce jour là sur
le marché il ne va pas hésiter à l'alpa
gay
dissidence il y avait le sens quand ça
marche
[Musique]
le duel el harrach simonet c'est une
vieille histoire de rivalité dans cet
arrondissement jusqu'à présent danielle
simonnet en est sortie perdante
incarnant une gauche trop bruyante est
trop radical
bonjour soit candidate pour les
élections législatives
celle sur le 20e et le 19e
temps de glace
cette fois ci elle bénéficie d'un atout
majeur une armée de petites mains qui
quadrillent la circonscription
[Musique]
j'ai plein de militants fabuleux et qui
en plus pour bon nombre d'entre eux
viennent de s'engager et certains au
lendemain de la présidentielle vote la
semaine dernière voilà donc c'est
toujours le jeu ils se moquent de moi
parce que j'arrive plus à mémoriser les
prénoms voilà on est trop nombreux
elle a 36 ans et elle ne pensais pas un
jour tracté pour un parti politique
mais la création de la nuque baisse il a
décidé
mon militantisme a commencé vraiment
avec debout donc reparti à un moment en
2016 on voulait vraiment réinventer la
politique par des nouvelles têtes
arrivent et ça s'est poursuivi avec la
primaire populaire parce que je voulais
vraiment une union de la gauche cette
fois-ci l'union est là et c'est vrai que
c'est la première fois que je me dit
mais ça me plaît de le faire pour des
pour une union et pour plusieurs partis
différents parce que je me retrouve dans
le pcf sur beaucoup de
sujets sociaux je me retrouve dans les
verres sur d'autres sujets plus
écologique et cette union c'est vraiment
quelque chose le pendant de nombreux
attendre quand il ya des terrestre je
n'ai pas hésité pas à aller voir les
gens sur les terrasses
je me fasse à la vague insoumise en un
peu plus de dix ans le nombre
d'adhérents au parti socialiste lui a
été divisée par dix et sa ligne
politique oscille entre
social-démocratie à réinventer et social
écologie a imaginé la mia et la rage en
convient il faut tout repenser
doit se poser un certain nombre de
questions sur ce qu'est être socialiste
aujourd'hui et surtout comment est-ce
qu'on est socialiste aujourd'hui il ya
aussi sur les questions de fond sans
doute une forme de radicalité qu'on a
perdu et à laquelle personnellement
j'aspire ma génération aspirent moi j'ai
été élue la plus jeune députée
socialiste de la précédente mandature je
vois bien que j'ai pas la même vision
que certains députés qui voulaient pas à
les nommer son élu depuis presque avant
ma naissance quoi donc on n'a pas la
même façon de voir les choses
ce soir là la candidate dissidente à une
heure pour convaincre qu'elle dispose
d'un espace politique entre l efym
emmanuel macron débat sur bfm paris elle
va affronter naturellement danielle
simonnet un candidat à l'air et le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
le débat chez vous une émission
exceptionnelle durant une heure je
reçois ce soir le candidat de la
quinzième circonscription de paris
circonscription dans laquelle on t'aime
la gauche n'est pas puni
à la mairie à djibo de jaurès et je
reste
étant jeudi avec les socialistes et je
n'ai pas envie qu'on donne l'impression
que le premier tour est joué avant tout
mais moi mon adversaire c'est pas la mia
et la rage c'est moins mal gassama en
toute fraternité mais parce que je suis
hors indiqué avait accord avec votre
problème et je souhaite vraiment que
monsieur emmanuel macron soit mis en
minorité à l'assemblée nationale très
vite quand on aborde les réponses
concrètes à apporter aux problèmes des
habitants les deux femmes vont devenir
des alliés dans l'opposition aux
candidats des manuels maximum
quand il ya eu 110 suppressions de
contrats aidés par emmanuel macron ce2
au début de son quinquennat
110 suppressions de contrats aidés pour
les associations du xxème par n'importe
quelle association celle qui fonde la
dose de voir celle qui accompagne nos
aînés emmanuel macron
énormément âge et lisez les bailleurs
sociaux
et sur le plateau la guerre des gauche
n'a pas eu rien
merci mon avis aux consoles et bat
sexuellement elle est globalement les
mêmes idées et c'est pour ça en fait
qu'elles ne peuvent pas s'affronter
frontalement sur la politique
politicienne peut-être mais quand on va
dans le fond des idées on se rend bien
compte qu'elles sont quasiment sur la
même ligne le 19 juin dernier danielle
simonnet a été élu député
la dynamique unitaire a été essentielle
et les étiquettes partisanes n'ont pas
véritablement joué alors que certains
pensaient que quand c'était un candidat
france insoumise il y aurait du côté
d'une partie de la gauche une forte
répulsion c'est pas vrai ça n'a pas
beaucoup joué il y a dix ans le parti
socialiste était plus puissant que
jamais il détenait l'elysée la majorité
à l'assemblée nationale le sénat la
plupart des grandes villes la quasi
totalité des régions son déclin et son
ralliement à la gauche radicale signifie
t'il que la social démocratie n'a plus
d'avenir en france
mais s'il ya une démonstration qui peut
être fait avec la crise sanitaire c'est
que ce sont des solutions sociales
démocrates qui ont été choisis pas des
solutions libérales et encore moins
radicale ce sont les méthodes et même
les finalités de la social-démocratie et
bien on défend les services publics on
redistribue davantage on fait en sorte
que l'état joue son rôle on discute
davantage avec les partenaires sociaux
que ça ne se faisait précédemment on
essaye d'adapter le travail à cette
nouvelle réalité le climat devient une
obligation
eh bien on est obligé de faire de la
planification
quel que soit le contenu qu'on lui donne
le mauvais et via d'abord de deux
solutions social-démocrate pour kerry
social démocratie il faut qu'il ya un
interlocuteur en face d'elle il faut
qu'ils aient un capitalisme qui négocie
et il capitalise finances et négocie
rien il dit le contraire inhibé coûté
moi je m'en fiche de vous je parle pas
avec vous ça ne trace pas faire une
usine où je commente les cadences et
puis vous n'êtes pas contents les
ailleurs
donc si vous voulez la difficulté pour
la social démocratie c'est jusqu'à la
pas d'interlocuteur alors les partis
issus la social-démocratie est ce qu'ils
ont tant à venir oui s'ils deviennent
des parties de la rupture
le ps va-t-il totalement se fondre dans
la radicalité ou cultiver sa singularité
las nubes va devoir affronter un défi de
taille
survivre à l'épreuve du temps
[Musique]